I was wondering if he was going to end
with a joke or be serious but he's
making a point he's making a point
always good to have Trevor nah here
we're going to begin with this the story
about President Trump who is promising a
Corona virus vaccine this year no matter
what his top medical advisers say about
it the president claims that CDC
director that's Dr Robert Redfield
misunderstood the question about a coid
vaccine yesterday now Redfield was
testifying on Capitol Hill at the time
and was asked when a vaccine would be
ready for Mass distribution if you're
asking me when is are going to be
generally available to the American
public so we can begin to take advantage
of vaccine to get back to our regular
life I think we're probably looking at
third late second quarter third quarter
2021 no I I think he made a mistake when
he said that it's just incorrect
information and I called him and he
didn't tell me that and I think he got
the message maybe confused maybe it was
stated incorrectly Redfield also
testified that wearing masks may offer
better protection for people than a
vaccine Mr Trump then said Redfield was
mistaken about the effectiveness of
masks only on CBS This Morning we are
joined Now by former CDC director Dr Tom
freden Dr freden good morning to you
exactly the person we want to talk to
today the CDC is considered the gold
standard in public health it's been at
the Forefront of every prior public
health issue in this country but now
with the Corona virus we've seen it
sideline there are reports of scientific
guidance being revised by political
appointees and now for the second time
you have the president contradicting the
head of the CDC How concerned are you
about all
this well we've seen both the FDA and
the CDC unduly influenced by politics
when it comes to emergency approvals
when it comes to recommendations and
that's very problematic because uh we
want to have a safe effective accessible
and trusted vaccine a vaccine is a
really important tool in public health
we love vaccines but in order to get
people to take it we've got to be able
to trust it and that means we need
complete transparency on the information
from the drug companies that means it Go
needs to go through the standard process
of the FDA and the CDC that can be done
quicker but it has to go through that
process no cutting corners on safety and
it comes to a vaccine it's one tool it's
not going to make this virus disappear
there's no fairy tale ending here to the
pandemic if we have a safe and effective
vaccine we should get it out as soon as
safely possible and when we do that
along with masks and handwashing and
being more careful and finding and
stopping cases and clusters we can get
to a new normal but it's going to take
all of us working together there are a
lot of questions about the credibility
of the CDC at this moment in time uh in
2018 when Dr Redfield took the job uh he
he choked back tears as he vowed to
maintain the Integrity of the agency uh
as a datadriven science organization do
you think think he's kept his
promise well when I look at things on
the CDC website that aren't
scientifically justifiable and it were
written not at the CDC headquarters in
Atlanta but in Washington by people with
no special experience in public health I
look at that as almost like someone
vandalizing a National Historic monument
and writing graffiti on it and that kind
of material on the CDC website should
not be there um it's not acceptable it's
unprecedented it has not happened before
and it's unfortunate because there are
thousands of really good documents on
that website it's had 1.6 billion clicks
and we need to be able to trust it yeah
Dr Fred your shot is frozen but we can
still hear you so we're we're going to
continue what does Dr Redfield need to
do right now to reassure the American
public that politics is not going to
influence the information on the CDC
website and also the broader vaccine
push well when it comes to the vaccine
what we need to see is going through the
FDA advis advisory committee the CDC
Advisory committee and um when it comes
to CDC they have to have standard
guidance that's scientifically proven
and I would really think it'd be even
better to hear not just from Dr Redfield
but from the specialists in the
infectious diseases in the respiratory
diseases that uh this is one of uh these
are the world's experts on how to
control an infectious disease how to
control a respiratory infectious disease
the more we hear from them the more we
can understand what's happening and
adjust so that we can work together and
keep the virus at Bay there's only one
enemy here it's a virus yeah one of the
things that the president said that um
Redfield was confused about was about
mask when he said that mask offer more
protection than a vaccine where do you
stand on
that well it's really kind of an apple
versus a theoretical orange on the one
point on the one hand masks are really
important and what we've learned clearly
is that uh the more people wear them
consistently the more you can protect
everyone you protect others and you also
probably protect yourself and maybe even
protect yourself from severe illness so
masks are really important a vaccine we
don't know what the effectiveness is yet
we don't have the studies no one knows
so we'll have to see what comes back in
terms of those studies but even very
good vaccines don't take most diseases
off the table you've still got to do
control measures we need a comprehensive
response if we're going to get past this
and through it together you're standing
fir
of mask you're standing firm about the
importance of mask I think we have to
keep emphasizing that that's why people
are so confused because they get keep
getting conflicting messages from people
who are not
scientists wear a mask watch your
distance wash your hands all of those
three WS are really important if we do
that we can get back toward a new normal
with fewer deaths already we have a
failed us response we're hitting 200,000
deaths tens of those tens of thousands
of those deaths didn't have to happen
and millions of lost jobs didn't have to
happen if we had had a science